but you find it like because I am you
know a recovering alcoholic I do clubs
every night
Ryan and there I am it is a difficult
thing to navigate in terms of just
interests in terms of seeing all the
drinking and the partying and everything
that goes on and then me still trying to
be a part of you know I want to be a
comedian and still want to be able to
you know bond and connect in that way I
find it to be difficult at times you
know especially when because I don't
know if you know this but in this last
year I've been really dry like I have
been to two meetings this year right
that's and so I'm in my response it's so
we're responsible yeah and I am I have
to admit I'm very moody yeah I'm I'm a
dry drunk right now
I'm very um and I just find myself at
the clubs even there are things in my
head like oh what if I did
you know what would happen you know like
I think it's through even more than
normal yeah yeah and it always ends up
when I think things through like if I
smoked pot with Chapelle right now right
and then next day what would happen I
probably I think to myself I relapse I
can do whatever I want now and then just
the ball just keeps going and going and
so it is yeah it is really responsible
of me
I think the paradigm is mistaken if I
can just correct you please this is what
I wanted the there is a prevailing
thought not just amongst people who are
addicted to substances who have gone
clean and sober but I just think
generally in society that when you stop
taking the substance for which you're
addicted you are somehow denying
yourself something and the opposite for
me when I'm healthy in my head and it's
not always like this but but most of the
times these days I'm not denying myself
anything I am stopping doing something
which actually I love but I had
difficulty not doing so it the idea of
saying I want to have something that I
cannot have or know that I've relapsed I
can do anything I want I actually think
the opposite is true that I feel like
for me my alcoholism takes this
this manifestation which is it is an
allergy which manifests itself as a
compulsion so if I take the substance
the alcohol the allergic reaction to
that is a mental aberration which which
thrusts me into compulsive behavior to
drink more alcohol and so the cycle of
addiction continues oh you do when when
you get clean and sober is remove the
allergic substance which triggers the
the allergy it doesn't take care of you
in any other way other than breaking the
cycle of that but but any neurosis or
any discomfort that you that one pairs
not you Bobby but but you but me Craig
or anyone who has these tendencies or
personality types what it does is is the
you know it's all still there everything
that you need to deal with is still
there just like people I know I know I
know I mean it it's so funny because you
know I've been around you know recovery
since I was a kid right since I was in
high school and I know these things
right I've read the book I'd you know
I've read things you know and I know
these things but I'm just in I don't
know it's so weird I am in a specific
weird state or I just can't I don't know
what it is doing it not really know I'm
very moody and ask and she has to take
the brunt of it and it's really not fair
to her because we lived together here
right and she sees me snap or like you
know and or me being in these like crazy
like moods and I am a well aware of what
it is
right I understand what the root of it
because I'm just in myself and in my
thoughts right and she says it's it's
it's a nightmare I wouldn't ask you this
because you know someone has labile as
him he's so up and down up and down and
if you it seems like he has really I
said this before we were in there I
really do think you could have done
better but
major choices in that hi oh he's a great
guy but Bobby I think you would agree
with me yeah what are you doing sorry so
in his mindset is if I leave one thing I
have to replace it with another yes and
how do you break that idea that you
don't have to replace it with another
form of addiction or another compulsion
well I think it you know it goes back to
what I said earlier that you're not
denying yourself anything yeah you you
know so so it doesn't there is no there
is no scale or reparation like you know
if I don't have alcohol then what do I
have well what you have is release from
the thing that's make that's killing you
and making you miserable and psychotic
so alcoholics are the only people I know
that look for a reward for getting a
gift in the [ __ ] first place which is
you get the gift of desperation that
gift of desperation if you read it
correctly will give you the gift of
sobriety and now you want something for
that you lucky son of a [ __ ] you got
sober in the first place
so many people don't yeah they don't
they cannot connect to the idea that
room just it's not even the idea it's
just lucky enough for some for I'm so
[ __ ] grateful that I got some moment
of clarity that broke the cycle oh god
is Craig aware of your debilitating
video game addiction and other things
like porn addiction and all of that I
would imagine that I should really talk
yeah no I would I have I feel that about
everything like when I stopped drinking
alcohol it's just don't being an
alcoholic I just I actually I got more
alcoholic in an odd way but so I've had
addiction I have an addiction to porn
because I'm a Scottish Protestant and
the video game things and then
candy crush or but here's the thing
about about videogames that in my
experience not necessarily everybody
else's
I've never played so many video games
that have blacked out in hair carp
that I've broken the hearts of people
who have were miss fortunate enough to
love me
you know I've annoyed myself and other
people but but the scale of that what
the damage of these things said that for
me now I'm not saying that that's not
possible but for me that has not
happened yeah and I seem to be able to
put things down easier with the
exception of about a year ago I stopped
going on social media about three or
four months ago I stopped going on the
Internet at all and I experienced it was
drawl from that in a way that I haven't
since nicotine really which is a lot of
twenty years ago and that I think a lot
of people have and are unaware of what
are you how did you feel like what was
the feeling will discontent insomnia
wild mood swings depression with you all
of the friends that turn out yeah when
when you try to break an addictive cycle
it's very yeah this is why you're here
yes this is no I honestly I honestly I
listen this is something that I needed
to hear usually in this podcast I yell
at people and I tell people that I'm the
king and I and I make fun of
[Music]